yeah welcome to Suri and playing f drive
international master f drive okay let's
um you want to get some interesting game
in the Sicilian and then someone place
the dreaded see 3 yeah let's see many
possible lines just um try for normal
development here jack is playing all
this very quickly probably a.m. this is
all all theoretical line cut up late
night a six and take on c5 or is he
playing c6 hi I'm not sure maybe and
doesn't seem to be the case I could play
night be for him trying to to get the
night trying to get the bishop
and nights don't like night c5 maybe try
that that's an important piece no on d3
yeah I still to go here still no way for
him to avoid the trade ok so Queen
checks that may be Queen takes a soul of
gains a temper on the sea porn Bishop e3
I can probably really take on c4 and my
intention is of course b6 and Bishop be
sevens would be very nice I have gained
the bishop pair already but of course
the drawback is that i'm a bit behind a
development not like hopelessly behind
but a bit behind okay this is a good
move i guess he wants to use this rook
on the on the third-ranked maybe hmm ok
slow Bishop is hanging ok let's let's
try to get to the D file
yes hmm yeah how to play now the ship
age six is coming with tempo but I have
g 60 not a big problem all right don't
see em anything else anyway besides
getting the bishop to be seven but it
can can get Harry here h4 h5 if
everything else fails you can try that
he's from the Ukraine by the way glad to
know one won't flak for a change okay
then time he's catching a up a bit on
the clock so I'm still behind on the
clock but not fatally so what what
should he do yeah h4 h5 is third is a
simple solution was simple idea okay
nights 96 yeah of course it does p6 move
it weakens it weakens it's not move
without drawbacks Knight to c6
hmm Jaffa take knight c6 i will i will
lose exchange hmm yeah what size Bishop
f4 after that okay don't really see him
something better my ass please playing
this nicely not giving me time to to
really set up the pieces properly what I
would have taken the rock on ahead son
the big problem
look I rock t 1 yeah simple and strong
the eight was saying also of the Bishop
d7 he had group takes da so I must play
Bishop e7 I think this is very ugly now
maybe you can just take here and play
like something I Jack have three or
something yeah or this one from just
technical technical play get you to take
now I don't have Bishop d7 now I rook
the eight coming okay
wrong
okay black resigned yeah I polished b6
very nicely yeah if I cannot play b 6i
me now if i don't know maybe okay he
even had better at better moves but ok
let's let's just just go back proclaim
yeah ok so i cannot play b6 it seems
it's this position so bad now he's got
he's got some attacking attacking
potential that's clear but i don't
really think it should be should be
losing yeah the computer is suggesting
nice moves 98 you need to play something
like that you know that you're in
trouble and this just loses it very
nicely played before very in very nice
app i can i can retreat maybe but what
kind of position is this just just just
terrible ok here maybe I should take
after all the issue is after this yes
here yes an even stronger continuation
than what he played which was good
enough but here check here he has a very
nice smooth Queenie 5 and this is Major
it's a checkmate this is the checkmate
Red Queen geez have made
if I take it check it's very easy and
here you can just take 25 from is
completely killing then maybe here i can
i can put up some resistance with with
something like a five or so okay it's a
disaster this is just perfect play Luke
c7 yeah whoop dee dee 70 threatened and
then this just killed so a very nice
very nice win yeah I cannot play be six
but maybe this was was too slow while
all of that maybe roop the eight is bad
i don't know maybe be six hear that hard
to tell how to tell it's a bit it's a
bit time consuming what I did not a six
taking but interesting alright thanks
for watching